hop mais de dire jane a été au départ au
début très choqué par le par le tome par
la chanson je voudrais savoir pourquoi
parce que je pense que c'était les
respirations parce que je comprenais pas
les mots parce que c'était d'arriver
d'angleterre deux ans et parle français
alors je connais pas ces options un
season chansons où son cas hier
donc j'ai pensé que quelqu'un qui écrit
les chansons un peu avec mes aspirations
géologie complètement quand j'ai entendu
ça j'ai jamais vu lui le rayon tombe a
fait ça il est question de dh de les
chanter et tout ça et il m'a crié une
chanson qui était devenu de chopin qui
était l'autre côté et après ils me
demandaient de le faire alors si j'ai vu
et j'ai trouvé toujours le tune de
mélodies j'étais jolie et alors j'ai
chanté je comprends les gens qui a été
choqué par ça c'est assez étonnant mais
je pense que c'était assez pur aussi
après de le connaître je trouve assez
vieux voilà pour mille de dire après de
le connaître je voulais vous poser la
question que j'ai posée à serge j'ai dit
à serge serge dans les manades gènes
alors maintenant se dire djen djen
parler mariage
de toute façon et balaye les attentes
alors il est de l'homme il me fait
rigoler de première et première
rencontre avec lui et aigre menées
partout me fait rigoler après ça tout le
monde dit quoi vous êtes avec cette
affreuse cynique comme ça qu'ils
détestent des femmes et tout ça et je
voyais pas du tout ça moi à quand ils
ont mené à des partenaires et les
vestons conseil me fait rigoler et un
personnage gaulle alors là je dis moi
oui et était drôle quand yves était
formidable
alors il m'a séduit pas aussi drôle que
ça a pris que les gens disent qu'ils
étaient cynique et tout ça je trouvais
que ça c'était c'est parce qu'il est il
a un goût timidité annoncé c'est tout ça
parce qu'ils n'y étaient jamais sinistre
avec nous et tout est là il était plus
il est très tendre tanger gentille et il
est drôle alors ça donne un côté un peu
vicieux parce que les gens qui sont
vraiment gros c'est cgem allemand a les
experts
ex pense expense de quelqu'un d'autre
sur le dollar
oui généralement si celle ci s'est alors
oui joue comme ça mais c'est pas très
sérieux il laisse les gens défendent
malgré lui
moi je trouve pas mais je suis assez
content que les autres pensent qu'il est
si nice parce que comme ça j'ai l'écouté
privé pour moi alors j'ai un chien qui
mange tout le monde sauf moi
alors ça ça c'est assez agréable j'aime
pas les chiens qui lèche le mans de tout
le monde
j'aime qu'ils m'ont tout le monde et et
les autres je dis quoi vous avez un
chien affluent et bien vers moi il est
tout doux voilà ces jeunes avant de
rencontrer serge vous étiez déjà
comédienne et vous êtes donc passer par